muy buenos días es este un día
determinante quizás una semana
determinante para que los franceses que
se espera salgan masivamente las calles
para manifestarse una vez más contra
esta reforma pensional pues se han
escuchado por el gobierno justamente
cuando se sigue a lo largo de esta
semana examinando el texto de ley de esa
Reforma pensional en el senado
importante porque muy probablemente el
senado pudiera votar hoy el artículo
séptimo que en realidad es el corazón de
esta reforma es justamente allí en donde
se habla de aumentar la edad pensional
de 62 a 64 años los sindicatos para el
día de hoy hicieron una convocatoria
bastante importante en todo el país hay
más de 300 manifestaciones previstas Y
esperan que salgan a la calle más de dos
millones de franceses las autoridades
están estimando en un millón y medio lo
que hemos visto aquí en París desde este
barrio El Barrio sexto uno de los
barrios además de la capital desde donde
saldrá esta manifestación Pues es que la
gente ha llegado también y de manera
multitudinaria hablé con una pareja que
en realidad vino a manifestar de uno de
los sindicatos y nos decían hace unos 20
años y nos hubieran dicho que había que
trabajar por unos años más lo hubiéramos
hecho pero las condiciones hoy no lo
permiten los niveles de los salarios no
le permiten y sobre todo tienen
muchísima angustia o siente muchísima
angustia por el futuro de sus hijos
luego hoy el día también la idea es la
de bloquear el país ya podemos decirles
que todas las refinerías del país han
suspendido sus actividades no hay
reparto de combustible ni en las
refinerías de total ni en las de Epson Y
eso bien Podría ser uno de los puntos
que ayudaría a que el gobierno de por
fin algo de su brazo a torcer sobre todo
si este movimiento se mantiene a lo
largo de los días recordemos que la idea
de esta huelga es que sea una una huelga
indefinida especialmente en los
transportes cosa que ya es ha sido todo
un caos en el sistema de transporte
público aquí en París también del
sistema de trenes y como les decía la
refinerías Además del gremio de
camioneros que también están haciendo
algunos bloqueos en varias autopistas y
carreteras del país por eso rápidamente
Natalia mi segunda pregunta el gobierno
estaría preparado para este paro de
varios días Si es que se logra mantener
Bueno pues esa es la pesadilla de el
gobierno Aunque en este tiempo han
venido haciendo un poco como perfil bajo
esperando saber si finalmente se da esa
votación importante en el senado Y eso
de alguna manera pues ya les daría la
tranquilidad de que finalmente la
reforma bien podría pasar el gobierno en
todo caso lo que ha dicho es que si bien
respetan el derecho de la a manifestarse
el derecho a hacer huelga que es un
derecho constitucional Pues la primera
ministra Elizabeth el día de ayer en una
entrevista en televisión decía pero
poner al al país así de rodillas
bloqueándolo eso no es digamos la manera
de realizar las cosas pero como les
decía el gobierno no ha querido dar su
brazo a torcer ha concedido en muy pocos
puntos y sobre todo pues no esperan en
ningún momento retirar la reforma con
algunas de las personas que hablé aquí
de hecho decían no creemos ya que el
gobierno vaya a dar paso atrás con
respecto a eso pero sí pueden todavía
quizás ganar algunas cosas así que el
gobierno bien está listo y vamos a ver
porque ahora como les decía muy perfil
bajo y simplemente están mirando un poco
cómo va a ser la situación a partir del
día de hoy en todo el país